la sphère des enfants d'immigrés dans
les écoles maternelles de montfermeil
ils sont jugés trop nombreux par le
maire qui s'expliquera dans un instant
d'abord un rappel des faits avec jean
marc morandini enjeux du conflit ses
enfants ses enfants immigrés pour la
plupart que le maire de montfermeil
refuse d'accepter dans les écoles pierre
bernard a en effet décidé au mois de
septembre d'exclure du service public
deux directrices qui avait contre son
gré accepté des enfants d'immigrés
concrètement cela signifie qu'à compter
du 6 novembre la mairie refusera de
prendre en charge cantine garderie
service de cars et travaux d'entretien
immédiatement les associations
politiques syndicales et d'enseignants
se mobilisent pour organiser une
manifestation mais dans le même temps à
la sortie des écoles
la tension monte je viens et partage à
tout le monde moi mais faut quand même
pas exagérer le monde est raciste ou
d'obliger est ce que les enfants qui
naissent ici normalement son français
est la deuxième guerre et ont discuté
avec un groove la benne il nomme je suis
à rades fini sims arabe
voilà donc aussi concédé à prendre dès
hier soir coup de théâtre à 21h la
préfecture publié un communiqué dans
lequel on peut lire le maire de
montfermeil a décidé de ne pas mettre à
exécution sa décision le préfet est donc
en mesure de faire savoir aux familles
que le fonctionnement du service public
se rassurer à montfermeil et en
particulier dans les deux écoles mise en
cause et semble donc pierre bernard et
décidé de faire marche arrière
une attitude étonnante puisque quelques
heures auparavant il avait interpellé le
gouvernement sur le problème de
l'immigration et avait même reçu le
soutien d'un autre maires de
seine-saint-denis
alors monsieur